the big news today out of England
there's a new royal baby it's very
exciting Kate Middleton Pitt Middleton
Prince William welcomed their third
child a baby boy everyone is very
excited unfortunately the public has
only gotten a tiny glimpse of the new
Prince he was wrapped up in a blanket
they only showed him for a second take
it from me that is no way to debut
royalty I don't like to criticize the UK
but that's not how it should be done
there should have been a grand debut
where we all get to see the new princes
face don't you think so yeah that's why
that's why I can't believe you're
clapping along with this [ __ ] anyway
he's right but thank you it helps with
the whole bit that's why at great
personal expense I've had the royal
child flown from London to our studio
we're the only show that has and ladies
and gentlemen the Royal baby with a jet
pack
let's get the Royal baby in here
[Applause]
fantastic flew all the way across the
pond from London to be with us what's
that that's incredible I've just heard
the Royal baby wants to make an even
more dramatic entrance let's see what
he's up to now what's he doing he's on
water skis
[Music]
[Applause]
just credibly exciting I've never seen
anything like this his weight strength
at that age so amazing all right there
he goes
look at him handle those corners well I
think that's too wonderful and proper
entrances for the Roy what's that a
third there's a third traumatic entrance
the royal prince would like to make he's
coming back the Royal Highness the Queen
its Queen Elizabeth
this is incredible and I'm being told to
my pretend earpiece that the queen is
going to attempt to launch the new Royal
baby across our studio into this waving
royal bassinet Queen whenever you are
ready please launch
[Applause]
hey everybody let's pretend as if it
worked just as it did in this footage
from rehearsal
[Applause]
you
you